esprit 8 a été le directeur du bureau 5
suspendant 8 ans et l'insee américain et
l'esprit 8 bien qu'ils soient qui était
directeur du bureau of sound sus et
contre le stage de statistiques est non
raciale il veut retourner il a commencé
à le faire d'ailleurs dans le
recensement américain perd des
statistiques des payer d'origine et non
pas raspaud là une proposition il
s'explique très bien sur ce point on a
regardé aussi les questions soulevées
par les questions de statistiques des
nationalités en russie au fait je vous
épargne madame desbassyns intérêt à lire
ce livre parce qu'elle verrait ce que
c'est que de faire un travail précis et
notamment de voir ce qui se passe dans
trois pays au moins hors de la france
qui utilisent assez massivement les
statistiques ethniques qui a dû bien et
il ya du mal mais c'est de ça qu'il faut
discuter c'est pas faire des grands
discours sur ça va tout changer et ça va
permettre et c'est s'est par contre
universalis moi j'ai jamais prononcé le
mot d'universalisme c'est pas ma
question c'est d'aimer questions sont
relativement et même très concrètes et
une de mes questions importantes
c'était la question de la mixité parce
que l'idée de statistiques ethniques
s'éviter que ben voilà on a une seule
origine
on est juif et on est arabe et non
surtout en france la mixité et a
développé une très grande partie des
notamment des immigrés par an si vous
prenez le recensement voilà une bonne
façon de faire la statistique
vous apercevrez que dans la génération
des 20 30 ans près de la moitié des
personnes qui vivent en couple vivent en
couple mixte à moitié des immigrés pour
les générations plus anciennes ces
témoins donc qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
déclarer quand ils sont dans un couple
où il ya un membre du couple qui est
originaire d'algérie et puis un autre
membre du couple qui est originaire ou
bien de du nord de la france voilà la
question et ensuite de génération une
génération après ça va encore à se
compliquer la question de la mixité des
origines une question essentielle
[Musique]